okay hello everyone
well turns out this is the 500th episode
of
live ceoing behind the scenes in real
life software development
so
hopefully this one's going to be really
easy he says
we are talking right now about the
function cloud sync
and
the objective is
okay synchronization of local
directories and cloud directories
okay but so this is a hard problem right
okay now who's who's speaking here yeah
um
not too hard hopefully
i mean it's not trivial there's some
machinery in the background that needs
to happen but um
we have some ideas so
but i don't understand for example if
you have a file open on your local
computer
and it synchronizes from underneath you
what's going to happen
oh i said i see what he's saying yeah
yeah i
we're not really trying to solve any
conflict resolution uh
what are we going to what's going to
happen what actually happens if a file
gets rewritten the file is open
in the operating system on your computer
and something comes in and rewrites it
what happens
because that's what this is going to end
up doing
does it depend on the application or
what does it do
it kind of depends on what what that
process does if the file changes
underneath
but um
so for us we're primarily dealing with
notebooks so the question is what do we
do when the file changes underneath
[Music]
i think
the front end usually detects that and
um well let me think
if it disappears there is a special
mechanism for that and it shows a
message
uh
if it changes underneath
um
i think you would just overwrite that
probably
well okay so just to understand
i don't think that is what i mean what
happens with things like dropbox and and
um
uh
and and so on is um
that
you know it says or at least in our
application
what it does is to say
um it renames it to untitled whatever
right it renames the previously open
file to untitled whatever now that may
be our behavior
and then the other one just shows up
with its new name i mean with the with
its stat you know foo dot and b type
name you get what i'm saying
yes and that's part of the proposal here
if you scroll down a little bit
uh
there would be
an option override target or maybe use
something else
where
you can choose what to do in that case
but it's basically a function of this
cloud sync function um
when it detects that case okay so let me
just understand what we're thinking is
going to do
so cloud sync you can run it on a
directory
and it will attempt to synchronize that
directory in the sense that it will keep
the newer version of every file is that
correct
that will be uh a sensible default yeah
but it's not going to try to resolve
conflicts
yeah but so what it should do by default
is there are cases in which it's safe
does it know when it's safe to
do
that overwrite in other words if the
file on system a
had not been touched since
if they had forked
if no change had been made on system a
after the fork and only system b had
been updated we know it's safe to to
overwrite
do you get what i'm saying
otherwise it is not
um the question is do we keep
information about
any sort of fork points i'm not sure how
easy that is well okay so here's how you
tell right so you know
when each file was created right you
have the creation date for each file i
mean the last modification date for each
file
if it is the case
i see so the issue is when yeah when
were they in sync
okay well that depends on when cloud
sync was last run if we assume the only
synchronization is through cloud sync
right
then if we know when cloud sync was last
run and we look at the mod dates we can
tell
whether it was okay or not
we could do that that was not part of my
idea here because that would basically
make it stateful right so you keep
information around on your local file
system or somewhere
that tracks when you called it last time
and so on i think you'd have to do that
i can't see how it could work without
that i think you just corrupt files
without that
right i mean
we would always just take one or the
other so it's not like we would within a
file
that's not so obvious to me if the file
is open on one of the machines it's not
so obvious to me
now what happens if there is syncing to
multiple computers
so in other words what you've got is
the situation like the one that i have
where i have multiple machines that i
use
right
and
it's got to for every one of those
machines
it's got to know you know it's got to
know when it comes back to life and so
on
can we in fact solve this problem or not
or is this just going to be a mess
where it keeps on breaking people's
files
what i mean so
go ahead i mean i i agree the two-way
sync is certainly
harder
i think with one-way sync which is also
useful um
[Music]
that isn't so much of a problem
and why is a one-way sync
useful other than as a backup to the
cloud
you could see it as a backup you could
also see it as a way to publish your
whole local directory
uh or
yeah you know backing up your cloud
files or backing up you know just uh
copying your cloud files to your locals
i understand this is what i used to do
more than a decade ago before i started
using
these um
uh
um you know own cloud and dropbox and
all these kinds of things right
that's what i used to do and i mean i
used to have a separate set of
directories that were
um i think i called them portable or
something
and they were always getting copied over
you know from one thing to another it
was pretty grotesque actually
um
and not very useful
i mean it was it was necessary because
that was the only way to have something
available on a local machine in many
cases
um
all right let's let's review this little
bit more so the thing that we think we
can do
is
just
you know
if there's a if there's no file there if
it's just virgin territory
we can put files there that's easy
enough
right
okay if there is already a file there
and
then there's all kinds of logic about
whether we should overwrite warn
make two copies whatever else
but if this is going to be used as an
ongoing synchronization it's absolutely
hopeless unless it can deal with the
file already being there
am i making sense
sure i mean otherwise just a backup
basically
and i wouldn't even call it a sync it's
just a you know back it up to some place
that hasn't been backed up before
um
okay
and i don't quite understand i mean it's
usually kind of complicated if you've
started to do a sync and then your wi-fi
goes down
then have you blown away the file i mean
that has to be done very carefully and
atomically so to speak
am i making sense
yeah
otherwise you could end up with a
situation where neither file is there
and where you just lost your data
so i don't quite know how to do that i
mean that means that it has to be local
to
i don't know how to do that and do we
know how to do that i mean
one way would be to download the file to
some other place and then perform a move
that does not depend on the network at
least
yes and i understand that
that's probably a reasonable way to do
it although i don't know whether that's
you know one time in a million that
might fail because the machine like
crashes right when the move is going to
happen
and the concept that we might lose
somebody's files is really not an
acceptable situation
um
i don't know if you can shoot for being
more reliable than the file system
itself
perhaps not perhaps not
um
i mean hopefully move is atomic so that
it
uh
okay so now
okay cloud sync
to a cloud object directory okay cloud
sync for cloud object directory to a
local directory okay but the question is
that's amusing to use the two-way rule
that's a cute idea
it's a cute idea
we haven't done that but i mentioned a
little
little out there maybe but on the other
hand it doesn't make it very explicit so
i like we haven't we i think it's cool i
think it's a good design pattern
um
to a corresponding location in the cloud
yes
so that's also about debate of course
how exactly that should work but that is
well i think it might want to go into
something in the cloud that is called
uh
local sync or something
some such
or local files or some such other thing
or
some other top-level rapper that
somebody could readily set as the top
level of their file system in the cloud
but that isn't just the raw
i mean
i think both ways round
it should go by default into some folder
you know you could set it to go to
somewhere else but by default
it should go to some folder that
identifies what it is
you know will from cloud files or
something and i don't know what the
documents directory or some such other
thing should be the defaults presumably
i mean obviously you can tell it to go
to some raw file system raw place in
your file system
okay so now the next question is
is this something that happens
automatically
or when does it happen
right so
as far as this function itself is
concerned i was not imagining that i was
thinking of it as something you call and
then it does its job and then it's done
but it could certainly be the basis for
something that runs in the background
like a dropbox thing
okay what is this the purpose of the
function is to promote a potentially raw
file
so this is a bit of a
extra nice to have i would say but
right now we have that problem in the
cloud where if you create a file
directly with the kernel not through
cloud object operations
then
it does not show up in certain cloud
objects operations like uh
the file explorer might not show the
file or if you ask for cloud objects
open close
you would not get it and so on and
that's because there's no metadata entry
for it in our database
i understand that but so why aren't we
showing a thing when you go to the cloud
file system why aren't we showing a
little um
little tile somewhere that says
uh you know raw local files and you
click it and it actually runs file names
and so on and shows them to you
even though they're not manageable as
cloud objects
see what i'm saying
so it's not investing you could do that
yeah it
to me it's questionable but it's worth
that effort doing all that uh when
really you want better synchronization i
don't think you do because i think that
in many cases those might be temp files
that are coming and going and and being
written very fast you don't want some
crazy synchronizer coming in and saying
oh let me go synchronize this file that
just got overwritten a thousand times
i'm making sense i i actually don't
think it's a particularly good idea to
expect to sync for those files
i think if you want files that are you
know properly cloud objects that make
them cloud objects and if you really
want to be using the local temp i mean
you're not going to synchronize the temp
directory that's like for sure not yeah
right
that's like the famous story that i have
been known to tell of you know you you
hire movers to move some some thing and
they are meticulous and they'll take a
garbage can full of garbage and they'll
pack the garbage
and
you know move it for you
which of course is the correct thing to
do given the specification of move this
you know whatever anyway never mind but
i i think this is one of these things
where packing
packing the garbage of what's in the
temp directory does not seem like a good
idea and i mean to to me the right
design there is just literally some link
you know from the file browser that just
says look at your local look at your raw
local files
and it brings up a notebook and it shows
you you know it literally just shows or
or you just run something which goes and
shows you that and it gives a link to
some workflow where you can learn about
how to use local file operations
that's what i think for that
could also work uh
i mean even then we would still need
this function i believe where you know
whenever which function
something that promotes a raw file to a
cloud object especially
but it's not automatic
i think it's useful
i would also say if if it ever happens
automatically behind the scene it would
certainly not happen for the temp
directory and it would also not happen
synchronously it would be an
asynchronous right which might be super
confusing to people
maybe but i i think it's also confusing
uh to be honest that
you know you just do a put to some file
and then it never shows up
in your file explorer well that's why
you should do cloud output
yeah
i mean i really don't think that's a and
if you look at the file name for raw put
you'll be some weird file name right
it'll be an actual file name
i mean maybe what we should do is put
into that file name
something that basically makes it clear
this will not show up in your cloud
object directory
if that file name was a you know the
analog of a do not reply email
uh
you know from line
right what is that right now what is the
um
we just look at um
oops
what did this just do
um
uh hold on one second let me just
go ahead and
um
you go to the
cloud
i'm not sure what you mean by the put
name i mean you can specify whatever you
want as a file name
you know
the cloud has lost my login
oh well
okay
no but by default
doesn't
what does put do by default if you don't
give a file name
did not just complain
let's find out
it creates an empty file specified name
okay so it requires a file name is there
anything that doesn't require a file
name
um
well obviously
yeah cloudput doesn't require a file
name but put does require a file name
i see but does put return
the
now what the heck does put return does
put return
what's that
it's just null isn't it
i see that's a shame because if it
returned the name of the file you would
see the name of the file as some weird
thing right
then you would kind of know or not i
mean
it's a little weird maybe but it's still
in your cloud home directory that's
where your cloud kernel
is operating i understand that what is
the name of that cloud home directory
if i say dollar home directory here
okay but that's not the same i mean if i
look at a cloud object if i say
um
uh
it is i think if i anticipate your
question
if this the raw file for the cloud
object is in that same directory
okay well then that's maybe the mistake
maybe the the home directory here
which i don't really understand so that
9df what is that
uh that's just a bucket for your user
you guys
okay so maybe what we should do here is
in that name of that home directory we
should make it clear that that you know
by by the naming of that directory we
should make it clear this is not a cloud
object file this is we should call it
um
you know local server files or something
do you get what i'm saying
um
yes and in in some sense that's also
something to be considered at least um
but let's say it was called
files
then that would make it that would give
some indication to anybody that that
isn't a cloud object
and and we're saying that's how the
kernel would start with basically if you
have to do a put that's the the default
directory but the home directory would
not be slash user files it would be i
mean it would be something like
um
you know local instead of that it would
say local server files there
on or something like that
dot files at some point it would be kind
of a hidden directory
uh
in
[Music]
in your home directory
well
look i i don't think that's right i
think that the right place to put it is
i think the right thing to do is to
signal that your home directory your
home directory here is not a cloud
object directory
you see what i'm saying your home
directory is a local server files
directory
right and if you said that then people
would not be confused that it's not a
cloud object store
i'm i'm not even sure about that i think
people would still be confused if they
do a cloud put and then i get on that
you know with the same name i think
people at least by now they they would
certainly expect cloud put is putting a
cloud object right
okay so the issue is
that a get on that cloud object name
will do the right thing everybody that's
all good i could take this right and i
could say get
a percent two and i will get back test
it's all good works just fine
right what i'm saying is
the issue is people think
that there is some correspondence but i
mean nobody thinks that there's a
correspondence between the temp
directory and their cloud objects do
they
temp directory no but files i think okay
okay but so fine so what we have to do
is is show them this is not intended you
know your local file system is provided
for certain operations that you want to
do that you do not want to put an
attempt directory but it is not intended
as a permanent cloud object store
it's intended as a kind of a buffer area
i mean what should somebody put in their
local server files
and not in a cloud object
what are they trying to do there what's
the point of those files
it's
i don't even think you have that that
much right to exist
it's if because if you want something
really fast you should use a temp
directory to begin with not even okay so
what should somebody use the local
server files for
it's basically
if you need something that works across
uh
different cloud compute nodes
but still
you want raw file access for fine for
some reason okay fine so then let's call
it local server files and then you know
you're getting something which is some
kind of cache
and it isn't the cloud object store
which is the permanent thing
and if if you open if your home
directory is a local server files
directory you kind of know
that
you know what does it mean local server
files it probably means i mean maybe
that isn't the right name maybe there's
a better name for it but you know it
wants to indicate this is not intended
to be
the cloud object store
see what i'm saying
i think that's the right thing to do now
i understand that means we would have to
migrate people some directories but
we're about to have a new url scheme
anyway so we're going to have changes in
that area but i think that's a much
better solution than some kind of
syncing thing which i don't think is
going to work well i don't think i think
it's going to be something where people
are constantly saying oh i've got this
weird bug it works most of the time but
it didn't work in this case because my
files were updated too quickly and the
sync didn't come through quickly enough
i think it's just asking for trouble
i i i think
and i think the right solution because
as you say
you know your argument is it's for
specific cases for speed where you want
to just access the local file system
right it's not intended that that's
where people store their files
am i making sense i mean it's just a
it's a sort of pseudo-temporary area
right if it is a separate area yeah i
mean it's separated what do you mean
what do you mean if i mean the the only
way to not make it if is to change the
file system so that all files have the
metadata to be cloud objects
which i don't think we want to do
maybe at some point in the distant
future that becomes possible
the problem with us is basically right
now it is the same area there's some
files that don't get promoted with the
metadata
that's just wrong that was not properly
thought out long ago
before the current team's time
i think i think
i think the right thing to do just like
i've been pushing to have the published
thing be a separate area
the right thing is to segregate these
areas don't intermix the files it's just
crazy to do that
just have an area called local server
files that contains these things that
are intended to be on the local file
system and do not put them in the same
file system you know same
you know
directory structure place
as the cloud objects
okay so you're not too concerned about
people currently relying on that and
then
well i mean we obviously have to think
through what the bridge is but but
there'll be some way to do it
you know
relying on the fact that they're in the
same file system what would they do
relying on the fact they're in the same
file system what would they do that
isn't kind of a crazy bug
um
i mean it's not too crazy i think you do
you know you would do output to some
named object so you do cloud put
42 comma
yeah some named object and then you
access it with raw file operations and
then you do get my name yep okay well
fine but i mean you can so why don't we
do this
why don't we say cloud put if you were
to say cloud put into the local server
directories it just puts a file there
and it doesn't put the cloud metadata
just goes blup there's the file
no cloud metadata
no cloud permissions nothing local
server files is not something accessible
in the cloud by other people for example
it is a local server file for you
and if you cloud put to that directory
all you get is the raw file
that's fine um but it's
i'm more concerned about the case where
you know somebody
um
[Music]
in the past or currently uses clock
catch to the cloud or some expression
and then in a
uh
in a cloud evaluation they use get
sorry in the past what
they use they use cloud put to get
something into the cloud
and then in the cloud evaluation they
use get
you mean cloud evaluate
not necessarily it could be an api
function
okay well fine so you know what
this band-aid has to be pulled off at
some point
okay
you know with the the idea of mixing
things which are local files without
metadata with files that have metadata
in the same file system is kind of crazy
and you know
the fact that anybody did that was
you know the the cloud object store we
have looked a bunch of times that should
we upgrade the object store to something
more like
you know to something that isn't a file
system based object store i have always
opposed that because i think file
systems work well
but nevertheless you know were we to do
that that would completely break this
right
this correspondence between local files
and cloud object files
yes
so we just let's pull off this band-aid
let's figure out how to do this
and let's figure out how to make it so
that
you know newly created files i don't
know what we do for existing files
there's probably some way to make a
bridge for existing files
but newly created files go in a separate
area
and don't get cloud metadata if they are
put in that area
that makes sense and the and the files
that are in the main file cloud system
cloud file system all have cloud
metadata so if you find a cloud a file
that doesn't have cloud metadata it's
wrong it's a bug
let's go look at this okay so
okay
what is all this about this is
you don't even need to worry about the
rest api i think um
well but it might be useful i mean that
might be something which people could
call
how does it do permissions and so on
so if you want to say i want to put a
file into i want to have a piece of code
that uploads a file
and it's some random piece of code
that's just calling an api is that what
you have in mind there or not
uh with the api
yes um
the api is i mean
the first iteration is there for our
rule from language functions to talk to
the server
but is it intended to be user exposed
in the end yes
definitely
possible okay
okay
um
so i think
one trick that's that's worth talking
about is how we preserve metadata
in the local file system
and and the idea would be to use
special hidden directories that contain
that metadata
uh sorry said it again for a second
so you know imagine you want to create
an archive of your cloud objects that
yes preserve permissions and all the
other meta information that you store
with the cloud object
then the idea is to store that in your
local file system
in a hidden directory next to the
primary content files
okay
sorry i sorry i spaced out i'm trying to
deal with uh some
other issue could you say that one more
time i apologize maybe scroll down a
little bit so that you see the next
subsection as well it gives you some
idea um so so you know
when you synchronize something you'll
have files that are basically the
content of the cloud objects right but
then you might also want to preserve
metadata like the permissions or other
options when you synchronize to the
desktop
yep and also the other way around you
know
later you might sink back to the cloud
maybe even to a different cloud right no
i get it i get it so the question is
well what happens if you if there was
you know if jim was a
you know a user
on
one cloud whose permissions you assigned
and that same name is somebody
completely different
is evil jim on another cloud how does
that work
presumably the permissions would be
particularly permissions yeah they
wouldn't make much sense what would
happen is basically
the permissions themselves are
represented using the user uuids
you know it's not like
so
it's just very very until the uuids
collide when the universe ends when the
uuids collide anyway so
uh exactly
right
every
atom of space has its own uuid and if
they ever anyway never mind
so are you talking about issues like i'm
transferring between clouds and there's
just different
users i've given permissions to on one
system and you want to specify a mapping
or something i don't i think the mapping
sounds incredibly ornate i mean i think
that
i think you just have to reset the
permissions when you've done the copy
but but i agree that you know if you
think that you're caching
look
basically if you think you are syncing
and the name cloud sync suggests this
you're syncing to the cloud from the
cloud to the desktop you can push it
back again to the same place if you want
to push it to a different place
that's a much more complicated situation
and to me that relates to our whole
attribute lattice permission system et
cetera et cetera et cetera it seems
complicated yeah right because it seems
like there are all kinds of security
questions about
uh you know who can
do you know
there's all kinds of horrifying things
that could happen if you could start
doing cross-cloud
you know user
you know cross-cloud permissioning so to
speak
i just don't think as a matter of fact
that's something we should
bear in mind when we're talking about um
these lattice-based permissions because
that's something that will be quite nice
for our internal multiple internal local
clouds to have the same permission
structure would be for most of them
would be good
so that's a that's its own issue
but
um okay so let's come back to this
i mean i i have to say i'm a little bit
skeptical about this whole thing okay
i think it'd be wonderful magnificent if
it could really be done perfectly i'm
just worried that what we'll end up with
is something which isn't quite
trustworthy enough that one can really
use it
because i mean okay let's take about
think about my use case for example
right now i have lots of files that are
sitting on synchronized across many
computers
um through
you know whatever the generic name for
you know dropbox like services is okay
and you know and that's and it works
very nicely
and it works you know that's how i do
all my work basically
is there are well i have a network file
system as well
and the network file system is scratchy
you know has all kinds of issues you
know it reconnects on some laptop from
somewhere and it then hangs and it does
this and does that you know it's old
technology i don't like it very much
okay so
i you know to be able to use our cloud
more i would love it if some part of my
file system was just synchronized to the
cloud
okay but i don't know how realistic that
is here now let's imagine that there was
a case
i just don't see i mean unless it's
really trustworthy it doesn't seem like
something one would use
because you know my use case all right
so
let's talk about another use case right
i get sent a notebook in email
okay
right now we have the nice player app on
ios
that allows me to open it on my phone
okay
as a raw thing with the local player app
now the other possibility would be
that somehow that thing
well if it's a cloud file that's sent to
me then i open it in the cloud and the
cloud app and that's all good as well
how would this affect that it wouldn't i
don't think that's not a relevant case
sorry i retract that
um
so
the question there is
um
what
uh
you know how good is this going to be
able to be i'm just really worried that
it's going to be one of these things
that isn't quite trustworthy enough
and then the question is what is the
fallback what is the use case that still
makes sense even if it isn't true even
if it's only for example
okay so the issue is this so let me let
me paint a picture that might make more
sense
right let's say i have a published i
have a directory of published files
and
okay i'll give you a use case right i'll
give you a use case
uh that actually might make sense it
might be easier okay
okay i've got a i've got a directory on
my local machines
and i am routinely i want that directory
to be auto published to the cloud
yep okay
so in particular
i am working on a file
maybe i'm doing it on some live stream
and i want people to be able to get that
cloud that file in the cloud if they
want to
so what i'm saying and and to get
reasonably you know every time i press
save i want it to be
i mean i
see that seems unrealistic i mean
what you've got is a is a you're not
doing incremental updates are you i mean
in other words if i have a 100 megabyte
file and i keep on pressing save what
we're doing on the local machine is just
incrementally updating pieces of that
file whereas in the sync proposal that
you're making here that whole file in
one go would be pushed to the cloud
correct
on a per file basis yes it would be
granular down to the file level you know
if there was a file that wasn't changed
i understand it wouldn't be copied but
yeah but i mean if i'm demon pressing
save
on my local machine
and and i guess the thing is you know
every 30 seconds is doing a sync it's
copying a big pile of stuff
yeah i mean there's
some chance of of optimizing that uh
pretty much like various backup
utilities do
but
that's
probably wouldn't be a v1 feature i'm
sorry what one once that wouldn't happen
right away i think
yeah
look i mean i think this thing about
keeping
a published file
in sync with my local version that is
somewhat useful
okay but that's a much more junior
feature than the whole thing you're
talking about here
in other words
part of a saying you know it's the one
directional thing right and that is
useful on its own
you know that you're local right
in particular what you want right
exactly
and there's no i see so that's the thing
where it's a single arrow sync
yep where it's basically a
the default is overwrite
target yep
well i admit that that's useful and it's
it's particularly useful if you can say
when you publish a file if you can put
something there and we could
implement that efficiently that says
keep this file in sync
right if the publish dialog contained a
check box keep this file in sync
see what i'm saying uh i think that will
be nice even though that's not
necessarily this function really
well it's infrastructure for this
function
right so in other words you could say
cloud publish blah blah blah
you know
and then there will be maintain sync
arrow true
now the question is can that be
implemented efficiently without
something pulling for the next 17 years
in other words is there a message
and i don't know whether there is i mean
is there anything that is generated yeah
i mean the the right way to do that
would be yes yes yes the right way to do
that would be
to have something on the local machine
which is part of the save mechanism on
the local machine that says does this
file have a tag that says it is going to
be
um
you know that it is intended to be
synced right and that tag i mean
unfortunately
well let me just think about this for a
second
the problem is how would you do that
without modifying the local file you
could certainly put something into the
local file but if you had it in
see this is this is the many screwy
things here
right so let's imagine that you had an
auto syncing file
no no this can't work this can't work it
can't work
look
let's say i have that file synchronized
across multiple local machines
i would get very confused i published
the file from one machine as far as i'm
concerned because i'm using
you know file synchronization
automatically between my various
machines i don't notice oh i did that
piece of work on this laptop where i did
that piece of work on this desktop
machine right i just don't know i have
no idea i don't think about it and so
the idea oh on this machine i set it to
be auto syncing but not on this other
machine
is not something i'm thinking about
do you get what i'm saying
right i mean that depends on where
that's even stored whether it's auto
syncing or not right
yeah right exactly but the problem is if
it's part of the published dialogue
right
does the publish dialogue could the
publish dialogue modify the file that's
the question is that a work is that an
acceptable thing if the publish dialogue
can modify the file then it's absolutely
fine then the notebook file contains a
thing saying i'm auto syncing and here's
where i'm syncing to
right i i'm just thinking about this i
mean right now
if then that would be fine then every
time you press save for that file it
would essentially run the auto sync code
and then that would
work i think it wouldn't be a disaster
maybe a little surprising
but an alternative would be
to use the same
thoughtful cloud
directory can't work think about it it
can't work
because
well okay i see what you're saying
you're saying that that would be
auto-synced across machines as well
yep
if you put that in a dropbox i'm pretty
sure it would synchronize
yeah i think it would synchronize too
all right so that is an alternative i
agree you know in other words your point
is if you sync the file you sync the dot
files as well
yep
okay i agree that that's a possibility
and that might be more natural
well
no it's not a good idea well i don't
know it's a complicated idea so here's
the point let's say you move one of
those files the dot file is not going to
move with it
see what i'm saying
if you move the directory it'll move but
if you move the individual file if you
drag the file in your
finder whatever it's not going to move
and i think that's super confusing
in other words you move the file and it
stops auto syncing
i don't think that's right i think it's
better to put it in the file itself
and that probably means
um you know that there's a button in the
publish dialog that says set this file
to be auto syncing
so that you know there's an action taken
you see what i'm
saying
uh yep
okay so then
then the workflow that we imagine here
is
there is a cloud sync that will take a
whole directory
local directory and push it to the cloud
and vice versa which is sort of a backup
the two-way syncing
i think is really complicated i mean i
i'm i'm just very skeptical that that's
going to work robustly
but i mean what's what's kind of
surprising is you're saying dropbox does
work robustly for you right yes but it's
it's had it's had decades of development
at this point
sure
um
okay this is one of these mistakes not
to make
right we're not going to recognize
all for that if you don't think we need
it no i think it'd be absolutely
magnificent to have it i just don't
think it's very realistic to do it i
think there are many many many
complicated atomicity issues and it's
just complicated
i mean look there are plenty of services
that do the same kind of thing i don't
know whether there is you know what we
had looked at before was piggybacking on
some existing
mechanism or service
i mean i assume we know that there is no
api for dropbox that would make this
work is that true
because that would require yeah the
reason we can't do that is because it
would require
a piece of our cloud to be synchronized
through dropbox
which i assume we can't do i assume a
user could not declare
i assume the permissions will not work
out so that a user could declare a piece
of our cloud file system to be something
that is synchronized with their dropbox
i'm pretty sure technically that would
be possible
no i think we looked at this before and
there was some some crippling
cryptographic issue that made it
impossible
but you see that would be a much better
solution i mean to me if i could run if
i could simply anoint some piece of our
client cloud file system
to be you know dropbox synced
then that will be great now now of
course that more relates to your okay so
here's a question is it possible to have
a staging area
in which we auto sync from that staging
area
yeah i don't know if that can possibly
work i just don't see i don't think it's
possible to get an external service to
reach into a piece of our cloud seems
implausible to me seems unplausible that
permissions could possibly work out
um
it it couldn't actively
push something into our cloud probably
not no but
uh i mean in a sense we could run the
dropbox client on the cloud server if
you have to
and well i don't think we can i think
there's a reason why that can't work
okay
okay look to my mind this is
you know the priority of this relative
to other things it's unclear to me
because i'm a little skeptical about
this
i'm a little skeptical about whether
this can be executed i mean and to me
you know we should discuss whether
uh
you know what um
um
i think ethan just sent something
through let's see if this works
does this work
my god is that a bitmap
what is that
what is that is that a bitmap
more or less um it's not really a bitmap
but locators in graphics don't work yeah
okay the paintings but not located
seems like a thing to get working before
we get cloud sync to work
it's just something very very different
no i am
there is work in that direction yeah
it's basically native graphics
that's the answer
and there's a lot of work in that
direction
right
right yes i'm aware the bit of
functionality that we'd really like to
have is making backups and restores with
the metadata right now you can do copy
directory to download and upload
directories but it's just the content
file
so from a from a design perspective
cloud sync was kind of tying together
those two things plus the promotion of
local objects i don't believe in my
promotion into one function but we could
do
cloud copy directory and have that be
you know with this metadata and
everything
well i think cloud sync is a fine name
for the thing that moves something moves
the whole directory somewhere
i don't know maybe it isn't the right
name i mean cloud copy directory you're
saying
okay so cloud copy directory cloud to
cloud or cloud to local
why i'm i think it's going to have
corner cases i think it's going to have
very insidious bugs
i just don't think it's going to work
totally fair i'm not i couldn't argue
with that um
but if what we're trying to do is a copy
directory that's i mean why doesn't copy
directory store the metadata why doesn't
it have an option to store the metadata
i think that's part of the design
question here does it yeah
do we even need a separate function i
think
there's there's certainly a lot of cloud
specific stuff in that sense okay hold
on
you say copy directory and you're
copying directory from
a cloud directory to a local directory
what's in that directory is up to the
copier so to speak so if the copier
chooses to put a dot file in that
directory i think it's it's prerogative
to do that
do you get what i'm saying
yeah definitely but then if we need to
add cloud specific options to cloud
directory that's what gets fuzzy so i'm
sorry to what to copy directory to copy
directory
well whether it's a separate function or
not i don't know but i i think
that
i don't see why when you send from copy
directory from the cloud to local
the fact that it drops a dot file in
that directory seems un unproblematic
i mean lots of programs drop lots of dot
whatever's i mean got lock files in some
cases or whatever in in directories i
don't think that's problematic no the
question is the other way around if you
take a clean local directory and you
copy it to the cloud obviously the clean
local directory does not have
the
uh you know the the cloud metadata file
in it so then the question is then that
is a case where you have to do some
promotion process
where you have to you know we have to
add in the cloud metadata during the
copy copy directory
right right and so all those all those
uh options that we have for functions
that create cloud objects those would
need to get added to copy directory or
some have some syntax to specify
permissions and and actually in some
cases mime types
you know this file all right
let's look at that design okay but i
think this is where we should be going
initially
and
i mean i'm not sure what sync means we
could use that name for this
i don't think that would be terrible at
all i mean it's it's it's something
which has a bunch of additional hair
associated with synchronizing with the
cloud
as opposed to a pure copy directory
which
would just copy the content
without copying metadata and
synchronizing and this that and the
other
and i mean the the thing that what we do
we have to design the content of that
dot
well from cloud metadata file or
whatever it is
and you have to then define for example
permissions
if it's with uuids fair enough
um
i mean this is an interesting question
should the permissions be user readable
in that file or should they be you ids
probably your id is okay i'm not
thinking it through clearly enough to
know
um
yeah i mean i think that file should
have some reasonable structure in it
and
yeah and that file let's say that you
had synced okay you've got a local
directory you know what it should have
the cloud base based directory in the
name of the file and we should have a
separate file in that the separate
metadata file for every cloud
you see what i'm saying
okay
do you understand because because
otherwise what will happen is you've got
a local file okay let's say you're doing
this you've got your local directory you
sync it to cloud a you then sync it to
cloud b
right you then bring it back
from cloud a
bringing it back from cloud a should not
mess with
the metadata information for cloud b
should it
it's got to be thought through i'm not
sure
do you get what i'm saying
yes it's not and also
as you go back and forth
if if you add files in different places
are you getting the union of all files
eventually
in other words if you add a file on the
cloud and then you sync it back again
are you just getting more and more and
more files accumulating probably yes
although it might make a bit of a mess
right in the unidirectional case that's
what the remove missing files optional
before or whatever you want to call it
okay okay okay
all right we have to wrap up here but
but i think i think we've got a
direction here let's roll back the
incredibly ambitious version of this
okay
and um
i think we've got a version here which
makes complete sense to me i think there
are some details to work out about how
those dot files work and so on
does that seem reasonable to you guys
yep totally
okay
good and that gives us more capacity to
solve other problems so this is all good
um
all right thanks guys and um
see you later